en 2014
j'étais étudiante en lettres supérieures
en hypokhâgne et notre professeur
d'histoire nous a demandé à la fin de
l'année d'écrire un article sur le sujet
de notre choix
après réflexion j'ai décidé de
m'intéresser à l'histoire du vietnam le
pays de mon grand-père et plus
particulièrement à la guerre chimique
alors j'ai commencé à faire des
recherches
puis j'ai appris à ce moment là que plus
de 80 millions de litres de défoliants
avaient été déversés sur la partie sud
du vietnam
cette opération appelée opération wen
qiang par l'armée américaine avait pour
but de détruire la couverture végétale
qui protégeait les viet congs j'ai aussi
appris donc un dérivé de ce défoliant la
dioxine avait contaminé les sols les
nappes phréatiques la faune la flore et
viennent alléger la chaîne alimentaire
les habitants je pensais aussi que cette
guerre était derrière aussi affreuse
fut-elle elles étaient visibles qu'à
travers l'histoire et le regard qu'on
lui portait au départ les experts
pensaient que la dioxine disparaîtrait
avec le temps qu'elle perdrait même la
moitié de ses propriétés nocives en
moins de sept ans pourtant aujourd'hui
des millions de vietnamiens souffre
encore des conséquences de cet épandage
massif
après 50 ans il existe encore 28 lieu au
vietnam où le taux de dioxine est
quasiment égal à celui enregistré après
les épandages j'ai été aussi
particulièrement frappé en apprenant que
donc la dioxine
ce dérivé tératogènes du grac terra
monstrueux causer des malformations de
plus en plus effrayante chez les nouveau
nés les enfants les plus touchés
appartiennent à ma génération et à la
suivante absence de membres retards
mentaux cécité surdité affections
cutanées digestive nerveuse cancers
lymphome diabète
les mauves sont innombrables et derrière
tout cela
des firmes chimiques américaines des
entreprises qui aujourd'hui ne
reconnaissent toujours pas leur part de
responsabilité dans le conflit
j'étais en colère
j'avais honte de mon ignorance et je ne
comprenais pas pourquoi devant une telle
injustice les médias réagissent et si
peu mais comme le disait mitterrand dans
ses mémoires à deux voies le sentiment
d'injustice ne suffit pas pour vaincre
la justice à cette période je publiais
également sur internet mais réflexion
sur l'écologie et mes petites actions du
quotidien à travers un blog nommé iam
drap
c'était ma façon d'exprimer ma croyance
ou potentiels de l'individu et c'est en
partie grâce à cette croyance que je
suis parti un an après à la rencontre
des victimes de l'agent orange avec
l'aide de deux associations
j'ai eu la chance de rencontrer trois
personnes extraordinaires trois
personnes avec un handicap différents
mais qui provient de la même cause la
dioxine et j'aimerais bien vous faire
partager leur histoire
alors voici duke duke à 33 ans
aujourd'hui il est professeur professeur
d'informatique et de mathématiques dans
une province d'hanoï j'ai pris cette
photo avec son papa duke est reconnu par
l'état comme étant victimes de l'agent
orange c'est à dire qu'il a il a reçu
des subventions
là on ne voit pas très bien mais dieu
qui a une taille très inférieur à la
moyenne
il a les membres atrophiés et il ne peut
pas se déplacer alors son père depuis
que son fils à l'âge d'être scolarisés
il a porté à vélo sur un kilomètre
puisque à l'école primaire d'abord et
puis arrivé au collège puis au lycée les
établissements étaient plus éloignés du
coup son père a acheté une moto pour
l'emmener et enfin duke est rentrée à
l'école normale supérieure pour étudier
les mathématiques
cette fois-ci universités étaient hanoi
du coup son père a emménagé avec lui et
il s'est occupé de lui chaque jour
en fait duke il est passionné par
l'abstraction et pas seulement à travers
les mathématiques quand j'ai discuté
avec lui il m'a dit qu'il s'intéressait
à la philosophie au bouddhisme il est
même végétarien
donc en fait et s'extraire des
contraintes de son corps par son savoir
par son goût de l'abstraction maintenant
je vous présente kien tiennent à 33 ans
également il est il habite dans une
province d'hanoï
il est lui aussi reconnu par l'état
comme étant victimes de l'agent orange
canal a une tumeur externe sur la partie
droite du visage et souffre de clore à
guinée
qui est une forme très sévères d'acné la
vie de kien n'a pas été facile depuis
tout petit il se fait opérer chaque
année et sans les subventions de l'état
sa famille n'aurait jamais pu payer les
opérations sa scolarité non plus n'a pas
été simple à l'école les enfants le
fuyait et la finit à son tour par fuir
l'école mais grâce au soutien de ses
parents et de sa famille il a néanmoins
poursuivi les études d'électricien parce
qu'en fait ce qu'elle tienne c'est
récupérer les objets les objets
électroniques surtout tous les objets
qu'on pense fini coupe ans mort eh bien
il les récupère il est récupéré il est
réparé et j'essaie de phrases qui m'est
venue en tête penser les objets pour se
penser soi même c'est comme ça que s'est
construite yen est aujourd'hui son rêve
c'est d'ouvrir sa propre boutique de
réparation
je vous présente ma nantes ndong tenzing
à 37 ans il habitait hanoi et lui aussi
il est reconnu par l'état comme étant
victimes de l'agent orange
tenzing est aveugle il est aveugle mais
surtout c'est l'un des plus grands
compositeurs de sa génération
ils jouent d'un instrument traditionnel
vietnamien le lan bao qui est composé
d'une corde suspendue à une caisse de
résonance et quand j'ai demandé à tous
pourquoi il aimait particulièrement cet
instrument il m'a dit qu'avec une seule
corde il pouvait créer des notes à
l'infini qu'avec une seule corde il
pouvait transmettre de la joie et
émouvoir
tengzhong n'est pas aveugle de naissance
en fait sa cécité s'est développée au
même moment
où il a appris à jouer du lan ko et son
entourage disait elle son père à
l'époque qu'il ne pourrait jamais
apprendre à lire la musique
pourtant tu ntoum rentrer à l'académie
de musique à l'âge de sept ans et il en
sort premier et depuis il fait des
concerts en europe dans le monde entier
premièrement pour faire découvrir
l'instrument qui le passionne et la
musique traditionnelle vietnamienne mais
aussi pour informer et sensibiliser la
communauté internationale autour des
crimes de la guerre
chacun d'eux a trouvé à travers son art
à trouver à travers sa passion une
métaphore de son existence un moyen de
dépasser toutes les difficultés
inhérentes à sa vie
mais malheureusement ce n'est pas le cas
de la majorité des familles
vietnamiennes des victimes j'ai
rencontré des familles qui n'avait ni
les moyens nécessaires ni les ressources
pour envoyer un simple courrier il pour
arriver à avoir des aides au vietnam
l'administration impossible il ya
énormément d'étapes aujourd'hui
une franco vietnamienne de 75 ans
important procès aux principales firmes
chimiques américaines et j'aimerais
conclure en ces mots donc voilà ce
qu'elle me dit le 7 novembre 2016 lors
d'une interview que je lui consacre pour
reporter le procès que je mène contre
monsanto n'est pas un procès classique
j'agis pour que les crimes de la guerre
ne soient pas oubliés pour que
l'ensemble de la communauté
internationale se mobilise contre les
échos steed et les génocides
il s'agit pour ces firmes de laisser la
conscience se réveillait d'assumer le
mal qu'on a causé et de se rassembler
pour le réparer merci
non